what you see in these pictures this is a
forward view of a transparent man or a
semi-transparent man and this is a
posterior back view of a
semi-transparent woman but what these
organs that are depicted these organs
secrete molecules into the bloodstream
an organ that secretes things these are
called glands
and they secrete these molecules into
the bloodstream that regulate other
parts of the body things that might be
quite far away from the organs the
glands that actually do the secretion
and so these molecules that regulate
other parts of the body these are called
hormones
and the word hormone comes from greek or
mo which means to set in motion so one
way to think about it these are
molecules that set things in motion in
other parts of parts of the body this is
really to regulate the body function now
this entire system of glands is referred
to as the endocrine system endo
referring to the fact that it's acting
within the body crin originally comes
from greek war to sift or to
differentiate something and it's a
system of organs or i guess you could
say glands that are secreting molecules
these hormones into the bloodstream to
regulate the body i'm not going to go in
depth in all of these endocrine glands
but just to give you an appreciation of
what they do and what these hormones are
all about we can list some of the more
common ones that you might hear about
so for example the thyroid gland
produces thyroid hormone this is a
version of thyroid hormone you see your
carbons in the dark gray your hydrogens
in the white you see your oxygens in the
red nitrogen blue and these big atoms
right over here these are iodine and
thyroid hormone plays an important role
in your metabolism in fact if you have
too much thyroid hormone that's a
disorder called
hyperthyroidism which would make your
metabolism overactive likewise if you
have too little thyroid hormone that's a
disorder known as
hypothyroidism in which case your
metabolism isn't active enough
you have
hormones like adrenaline that are
released by the adrenal glands that's
where it gets the word adrenaline from
it's often known as epinephrine and
adrenaline you might hear things like
hey so and so is an adrenaline junkie
which means they really like a thrill
and adrenaline actually does play a role
there it's involved in the fight or
flight response where it'll increase
your heart rate and cl increase blood
flow to the muscles and what's really
interesting about all of these hormones
is they have so many impacts on the body
because they're released into the
bloodstream and to different cells they
might do different things
this right over here is a variation of
estrogen which is produced primarily in
females in the ovaries but it also
exists in a male body and it's
associated with a lot of female bodily
function but once again not strictly
female estrogen also exists in males
similarly
you have testosterone which is
associated with
male function but it also exists in
females and it's primarily produced in
men in the testes thus the name
testosterone but it can also be produced
by the adrenal glands and in women it
can be produced by the ovaries
but you could also have a molecule like
insulin which you can see is much larger
than the other hormones that we have
looked at it's produced in the pancreas
and it plays a super important role in
how we process sugars and how we store
fat and scientists are constantly
discovering new roles for these various
hormones
insulin in particular you might
associate with diabetes people with type
1 diabetes aren't able to produce enough
insulin to take sugar out of their
bloodstream to have the cells absorb the
sugar insulin will bind to the surface
of a cell so that it will start taking
in sugar from the bloodstream people
with type 2 diabetes they have a
insensitivity to insulin so they might
have to take extra insulin in order for
their cells to take in the proper amount
of sugar but the big idea here is that
the endocrine system although it might
not be as obvious or it might not be as
well known as something like say the
nervous system it plays a pivotal role
in your body it helps regulate your body
it helps keep it at the right
temperature the right blood pressure
your heart pumping at the right rate one
way to think about this is the notion of
homeostasis
which is
derived from similar and staying the
same so keeping your body at the right
temperature regardless of what the
temperature is outside regardless of
what your body is doing there's a whole
series of roles that these hormones
which are released by these endocrine
glands actually do